tiens voilà saimone garfunkel et visites
de sites
donc nous avons johnnie to drink mois à
wall of you it's ok on a déjà à new
nouveau que you et voilà défaire pour
mes petites pestes souplesse et de la
déco c'est chiant elle c'est un pote bon
alors qu'est ce qu'on fait on les
badauds face à bâle les filles chapelle
du light champagne you like saint paul
les filles s'est bâti les voitures des
[ __ ]
ban champagne alors c'est quoi vos
petits noms what what you name hamada
magda et wonderful sa magda il gueule il
que asahi que c'est super moche c'est
quelqu'un te déglingué alors moi même
c'est patrick patrimoine bâti
va-t'en d'un opticien s'en fout et 100
foot je m'en fous tout le monde s'en
fout hein alors lui c'est very very good
pote very good friend of mind longtime
gollnisch fn fort mais on s'en fout
ben ammar mais c'est complètement pourri
c'est à bénabar nom marcel poursuit le
coach adjoint annie alors mieux s'en
fout